by shovel and sandbag residents in the
southern Austrian city of Clark and foot
are doing whatever they can to keep the
rising flood waters at Bay
but many of the roads on our rivers and
improvised obstacles to channel the
water or proving little match for the
power of nature
this resident says these floods are
unprecedented
I own
and at half past three I got up and went
to the underground car park which was
almost completely underwater I've lived
here for over 20 years and we've never
had a situation like this before
Austria's southernmost town of furlach
has also witnessed flooding and
mudslides
farmlands on ruin some homes are
completely underwater and the cascading
mud has blanketed houses and cars
across the border in Slovenia where at
least three people have died there's a
Red Alert warning in place for further
downpours
the owner of this business says she felt
completely helpless as the water
streamed in cheers
yesterday morning around 9 A.M it
started to flood in the parking area and
then all of a sudden the water Rose to
three meters high we could only watch
residents have their hands full as they
try to clear mud and debris from
businesses
oh what can I say the flood gushed in
and destroyed everything we came to help
we have a lot to do I'm here with the
owner everything will be fine but we
have one sleepless night ahead of us
slovenia's defense minister says the
country's Army stands ready to deploy as
the country braces for further flooding
Michael Apple Al Jazeera
foreign